[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what about keystone pipeline should
biden have kept that going it would have
been the fourth phase of it we've got
the other three do we really need it any
changes expected
yeah i think it's clear now that the
market thinks that's that was a mistake
um
you know
when biden took his mandate and and went
into the direction of green which was
you know that was his mandate from his
voter base we hadn't gone through the
risks of energy security which we've
gone through now and so we had amnesia
to that and all of a sudden it's been
brought to the fore through what's
happening in ukraine
most americans today my bet is that they
would vote for some kind of more
realistic phasing out of hydrocarbons to
assure energy security over the next 20
years while we take the profits from
that and deploy it to finding other
cleaner ways of powering our economy i
might bet again
every incumbent president loses seats at
the midterms but what you're going to
see in this midterm midterm election
is going to be brutal um i'm predicting
that even the senate may go the other
way oh wow it's it's it's it's really
ugly out there the house promoter pret
you know you you don't want to get into
politics in a discussion like this you
want to understand
policy and i think
um
my guess is that uh the midterms are
going to favor a more
uh
energy security mandate a lot of these
um
senators and congressmen who have gone
too far out on a limb
on green mandates are going to feel it
in their local jurisdictions
it won't be pretty um
so
that's why i think you know buildback
better as a bill will never happen
my assumption as an investor and i don't
want to speak about the pros and cons of
this it's just that washington now going
forward is in total gridlock
and will be after the midterms as well
there won't be any significant policy
coming out of there to the general
election which is good for investors uh
we've spent a lot of money we printed
three trillion dollars plus
um i think the market thinks that's
enough it's just that all of the things
that biden wanted to do
he won't be able to
yeah yeah so potentially a double flip
is what you're thinking of both house
and senate to potentially republican i
i'm investing that way and so i'm
thinking that is probably uh what's
going to happen
um i you know i don't want to talk about
the merits of you know that other than i
have to make decisions and i deploy
capital um you know i i see what's
happening i'm you know i it's ugly it's
ugly for the democrats and if they don't
figure out a way to get energy prices
down and food down
voters will take it out on them
in about 10 months
yeah what's been your take on the buy
now pay later sector so for example a
firm they think that they can become the
next visa or mx and we haven't seen
anybody get into that top four space of
the top four credit card processors uh
you know with discover and and uh
mastercard they think they can squeeze
in by using buy now pay later and these
contracts with merchants obviously
there's klarna after pay there's so many
other companies square about one what's
your take is this is this just a gimmick
no i i think there's merit in these
ideas but you look at most of these
business models is that
the customer acquisition cost is
significantly higher than the lifetime
value of the customer and so
i don't know how many of them are going
to survive but
there's lots of these ideas out there
but
their ability to raise capital to
continue acquiring customers is the only
metric you should care about and so
a lot of these new iterations of
existing businesses like robin hood or
sofi
i think you know robin hood stocks down
something like 80 percent and i'm not
saying it's following the model you're
discussing but it gives you an idea that
new new entrants
can can ride away for a while but in the
end you have to start making money yeah
yeah that's and i think
growth itself without profitability is
not sustainable and so
it doesn't mean that there won't be
value created in a robin hood i like
what they've done in democratizing
investing
but um
there comes a time when you have to
figure out how to acquire a customer so
all of these ideas are interesting in
the sense that they explore new ways of
doing old things
but that doesn't mean the incumbents
aren't going to keep hold of the markets
for a very long time and i think you're
going to see some innovation in the
visas in the mastercards certainly
there's an innovation coming in a
mastercard in a product called built
bilt i'm an investor in that project
they're providing credit cards to
millennials and gen zers that pay their
rent on their credit card to offset the
downside of credit rating so all of a
sudden when your biggest expense each
month is your rent
and you start paying it each month
successfully your credit rate goes
through the roof and so built was the
card that did that and it's growing like
a weed but it's basically a branded
mastercard infrastructure product and so
there's a new innovation on top of an
existing platform which is what built is
and i think that's very strategic in
that sense
now do you think that uh i mean you look
at visa and mastercard i think they
bring like 40 to the bottom line and
they're growing you know five to 12
percent a year and so they're bringing
so much profitability to the bottom line
do you think that essentially just makes
it impossible for somebody else to
compete like why bother or do you think
these larger companies will just swallow
up and maybe acquire so far say say
their price falls another 50 and they
just get gobbled up
yeah i think that's more likely i don't
i think that you know it's the jury's
still out on so far they've got to
continue providing all kinds of products
and services but where is the
profitability in those products and
services we'll see but you know it's
recently got its bank status which is
great and maybe they'll become a
significant competitor or they'll be
acquired by somebody else it's hard to
know um but at least they've got scale
at least they've got a lot of customers
which you can do a lot of things with if
you can figure out how to service them
profitably and a lot of these
innovations will be experimented with um
i'm always but you know i own all the
credit card companies because the
business model is very successful and
they're a big part of my portfolio many
of them are strong in terms of
redistributing capital
and so and i watch these markets like
anybody else i love innovation but at
the end of the day customer acquisition
the reason that 70 to 80 percent of
startups in america go bankrupt after 36
months is that they're never able to
solve for customer acquisition
the lifetime value is just not
you know is a lot less than the cost of
acquiring the customer and that's a
fancy way of saying they go bankrupt
advertising and they do and so you have
to keep looking at that as the metric
that you measure
but what i'm hearing is short ggpi pulse
star and lucid and all in on tesla
yeah i don't think that's right i think
the market's going to give a lot of
flexibility but you've got to realize
something for all of the hype about ev
the only company that's mass producing
is tesla so you may not like the price
point but if you want exposure to that
industry that's the stock you know for
ge for all the talk and everything but
they basically made less than 100 units
i mean it's irrelevant ford has a lot of
opportunity in the f-150 lightning but
they haven't delivered on that yet
uh meanwhile tesla is miles ahead of
them on so many different advances in
technology
uh it's hard not to when you want to
weight that sector not put the majority
of it into tesla and then just hold your
nose at the volatility i mean i'm not
interested in buying cars that haven't
been road tested by you know some time
in the market and the only company that
has that right now is tesla
nice uh so you mentioned you're pulling
away from financials we talked a little
bit about like the sofa and the smaller
ones does that also include square and
paypal are you kind of shying away from
those
i do own some square and some paypal um
they're the largest in their space i i
think they have the most opportunity in
terms of scale and so i keep them
weighted but they're they're not full
weightings full waiting for me is five
percent these are sort of one and a half
percent position so i'm i'm
that means i'm not 100 committed but i
am exposed because they provide
important services um it's a wait and
see for me to take them up to a full
waiting
got it uh palantir a lot of social media
talk about this stock uh kathy wood just
sold her entire position essentially and
palantir
what's your take on this one is it too
too undeveloped uh
any thoughts on this
no i do i've remained an owner of
palantir um
it provides it's
what that company does very few
companies can provide the same service
and so when you when you start to
understand how important it is to be
able to manage data and do it
effectively and do it cost you know in a
way that's cost beneficial and the
analysis can be done i mean you think
about any company wants to know what
their customers buy when they use the
product what price point they do it
their size and taste preferences if it
happens to be consumer good or service
and then of course to be able to
speculate using ai all of these are
within the purvey of helen tier and i
don't know of another company does it
quite the same way so for me again it's
a one and a half percent waiting um i'm
i'm not you know i'm not 100 there yet
but it's volatile and controversial and
of course kathy tends to do more
concentrated positions that's not what i
do in in maintaining diversification
and you know um
the remarkable thing is you can take
both approaches and get to the same
place i'm pretty happy with my
performance
and um i don't need to take oversized
bets on anything
yeah good point uh what about i want to
i want to pull us now back to the that r
word that recession word for a moment uh
i just pulled it up the 10-2 right now
is at a 22 basis point spread we last
had the inversion in 19. if we invert
again here is this just because of
uncertainty because of war or what would
you put the odds of a recession at
i i think the odds of a recession are
less than 50 50. you know i'm more maybe
it's six maybe it's 70 30 uh but that's
still pretty big
you know i get it but i mean i just
don't know the outcome or how long it's
going to take to get rid of putin so
that's one variable uh inverted uh yield
curve has to stay inverted for a lengthy
period of time for it to really be the
canary in the coalmine signal just
because it inverts can be because of
again geopolitical or some other strain
on the system but if you really want to
use it as a measure for recession you've
got to have multiple quarters of
inversion gotcha you go back and so
we're not there yet um
and you know we just don't know how fast
i think the fed will be muted i said
that earlier
and i think it's much a wait and see the
outcome of of putin's next move
in terms of of just how that would
affect and right now sadly you know
ukraine is less than one percent of gdp
it's not a major factor with the
exception of commodities like wheat
which are spiking
and we'll see what happens on the
russian oil embargo my guess is that
goes ahead
i i just feel sorry for both the
ukrainian people and i feel sorry for
the russian people
their lives are going to change for the
worse in a really big way
now if uh there's some research out that
if oil hits 150 dollars per barrel we'll
easily see an additional two percent to
cpi
now bloomberg's projecting seven point
nine to eight percent for the next print
that means we could see double-digit cpi
within the next couple months
what's your take on the potential of the
fed pull vulcaring us and and shocking
us with larger hikes it sounds like even
if we get large prints you're leaning
towards no but but i really want to
hammer on that if we get consistently
high large prints at what point do they
you turn on us well you said it
consistently in other words a big print
a single data set doesn't doesn't change
anything because you get a lot of
variance these days
and so but if you're going to have you
know very very strong prints i'd say
four in a row then you might get some
acceleration on rates
i don't think shock and awe is part of
uh the plan of the fed here there's just
too much of that happening in the real
world you don't need that in terms of
rates and so
you know i'm i'm more
constructive on fed i think fed will be
air on the side of slowing rate hikes as
opposed to accelerating them waiting to
see the effect of long-term oil prices
over 100 etc
but um
you know it's it's it's really you know
the news is volatile the vix is volatile
but at the end of the day
um i'm very constructive on on the
economy
i i think
vladimir putin has set his own end game
it's not a good one i said that earlier
and we'll move on to a more rational
leadership in russia
at some point i don't know how fast that
will take but you know
before he invaded i would have said he'd
could remain
um you know if his goal was to keep
ukraine out of out of nato just you know
threatening the invasion was all he
needed to do but something else clicked
in his head
and that's probably disease in my view
yikes yikes do you think uh sort of last
question here that i want to wrap up
with you do you think this emboldens
china with with taiwan at all
not immediately there's a leadership
rally over the next year i think uh
china is all of a sudden not the bad guy
in the news that's now russia they're
probably enjoying a respite to that
which is interesting for them
and um there's still lots of china
policy to deal with
china could be in a strange bedfellow
sense an ally to united states i don't
know how long they're going to watch
this
this mass murder going on in ukraine but
it must be getting uncomfortable for
them to be endorsing essentially a
madman and um
and on the world stage where they really
want to take a position as a a major
economic force it's an uncomfortable
place to be and and they would have
preferred i'm sure not to see this
invasion uh but now they have to live
with it and they've got to be very very
careful in how they communicate
you know if they come out and say we
endorse this that's a very bad place for
them they wouldn't want the same levels
of sanctions that russia is getting
right now
no any move towards sanctions they
already got terrorists i i think it's
playing itself out in a lot of different
places um
and may in the long run start to support
uh digital currencies and and digital
payment systems to be more efficient
that's what the outcome of this whole
ukrainian thing
may end up being
oh and that reminds me uh uh miners uh
esg changes are are you making big
shifts on the miners
yeah i am um this is relatively new
information but
um
you know i do a lot of work in indexing
and
most institute for all of the excitement
about bitcoin no institutions own it no
sovereigns own it they don't do it
because it's not a regulated
asset so the reason there's so much
volatility in bitcoin is that there's no
bid from an institution to hold a one or
three percent waiting in it it's just
owned by high net worth individuals it's
a respectable asset it's still under a
trillion in value you know versus almost
12 trillion in gold so it's not it's it
hasn't proven to be you know repository
for for for value yet
but there's a new problem emerging and
it's coming fast
many
uh jurisdictions many geographies are
looking at bitcoin mining
and the way that in the way that an
institution or sovereign up until
recently could get exposure to bitcoin
volatility whether they thought it was
going up or down was to simply buy the
public shares of the bitcoin miners
because over the last few years one of
the strategies of the bitcoin miners was
not to sell their awarded coin
they would keep it on the balance sheet
so that basically their asset base would
grow and grow in the balance sheet and
the shareholder would own
those coins but not directly through the
shares of the company so if you're a
sovereign you could buy the shares of
hud-8 or you could buy marathon or riot
or hive and and what these companies did
because they didn't really have sources
of clean energy
that was a concern of esg is they buy
carbon offset carbon credits and for a
while that worked
unfortunately that's not going to work
because
remarkably out of the private sector it
started with
blackrock
a lot of institutions are starting to
insist on audits of this strategy to
prove that you're really offsetting your
carbon and everybody knows these carbon
offsets are are so um
nominal such a such a wide margin of
error and there's impossible to audit
and it's impossible to know where your
source of energy really came from on a
percentage basis
so they're going to fail those audits
and what i've done and i'm you know i
don't know how early i am in this but
i'm sure there's going to be others
following me i've sold all my hive i've
sold all my marathon i've sold all of my
uh riot
wow
and all of those stocks they are
essentially dirty miners and there's no
way that they can prove they're not
and what i've done is taken that capital
and invested in the new mining model the
new mining model and there's an example
of it in northern norway the largest
shareholder of that one is a sovereign
a lot of people don't realize that
sovereign wealth funds
decades ago
were very very forward-thinking and
ended up taking very large positions
in the semiconductor industry so they
are some of the largest shareholders of
samsung and taiwan sammy and others
and they have access to chips in a way
that no one else does
and so in in norway when i was
approached by a group that was doing a
private investment they have formed a
partnership with the norwegian
government in a small northern village
and they're building out a massive
facility bitcoin mining
100 of the energy is from hydroelectric
at a very low cost currently under two
cents and they could lock it in at under
four
and so there's no
risk of a carbon audit because there's
no carbon footprint there in addition
what they've done is built a hydroponics
facility that is powered by the heat of
the stacks and they have a giant tomato
producing facility beside a canning
operation to make canned tomatoes for
that northern community and the
stakeholders or many of them are the
villagers it's 3 000 people in the
village and so the problem was if you
talk about you know building a new
mining facility in in america right now
your biggest constraint is you can't get
any equipment you can't get any chips
that was not the case in this facility
they got their machines in two weeks
because their largest shareholder was a
sovereign fund
in addition something else to know that
they will be making an announcement of
shortly they have found a way through
software to strip the network award so
when you awarded a bitcoin even though
you've mined it with hydro you're still
awarded a network reward and you don't
know where it came from it probably came
from a chinese operator or maybe one
that used coal burning
they can strip that out of the actual
coin and they call it the slag they
separate the slag from the awarded coin
and now the sovereign and the
institutions that own that norwegian
mine
have no risk
of a carbon audit wow and so now they
can own completely clean coin so
in an industry where you can have miners
that are clean esg compliant and miners
that are dirty the capital is going to
go to the one where there's no risk of
audit and so the what's going to happen
to the pe values of these dirty miners i
listed them earlier in my view it's a
personal opinion their ps are going to
get compressed their access to capital
is going to go down
if you own a company that is using
carbon credits to offset
you should seriously consider this
problem
i i would exit stage left which i'm wow
yeah yeah and then just to be clear for
for anyone who's not familiar
essentially if you're a dirty operator
and you're using natural gas to fuel
your operation essentially but you're
buying carbon credits to say hey we're
carbon neutral you're still a dirty
company
you're filthy
because there's no way you can prove
that your carbon offsets offset what
you've done uh with that you know either
coal or net gas the only sources of
energy that are going to be uh that are
going to pass right now that actually
functionally work are hydrated nuclear
hydro and nuclear power those are the
only two so i i'm not investing in
anything in bitcoin mining that isn't
sourced from there that means that
states like montana potentially upstate
new york are tremendous opportunities
for large infrastructure build-outs and
i have when i went to the senate last
week i made sure that i stopped in the
senator
from montana to make myself an
acquaintance because i plan on investing
a lot of money in his state if you like
that video wait do you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe